d'après plusieurs études les parents
passent 78% de leur temps à répéter les
mêmes instructions de base à leurs
enfants c'est pas vrai kédy il faut
tirer la chasse c'est quand même pas
compliqué on a donc trouvé quelqu'un
pour prendre le relais
[Musique]
c'est l'anniversaire de Mégane a une
grande capacité d'écoute
et elle raconte très bien les histoires
si c'était vrai ça ne pourrait pas être
faux et en admettant que ce soit vrai ça
ne serait pas faux mais comme ce n'est
pas vrai c'est faux dis blanc bonnet
elle saura toujours trouver le moyen
d'occuper votre enfant et elle ne perdra
jamais patience
[Musique]
Mégane prendra en charge les petites
choses du quotidien ce qui vous dégagera
du temps pour vous occuper des choses
importantes
[Musique]
il n'y a pas que la pâte qui se mange
qui dit tu dois aussi manger la
garniture
pourquoi tu fais le contraire de ce que
je viens de te demander des études ont
montré que si on force un enfant à
manger des légumes il aura moins envie
d'en manger une fois devenu adulte tu es
sûr oui les experts disent qu'il vaut
mieux laisser son enfant choisir on
appelle ça le partage des
responsabilités
qui dit il va falloir que tu ailles à
l'école j'ai le droit d'amener Megan tu
sais très bien que ce n'est pas possible
alors ce sera sans moi s'il te plaît qui
dit
excuse-moi t'en va pas comme ça non
attends lâche-moi
pourquoi tu t'énerves comme ça calme-toi
arrête là maintenant
Mégane éteins-toi tu en es sûr